[Music]
now there's a guest actor in this
episode and i don't want to name the
person because the this the story i'm
going to tell is sort of a personal
story uh
but it he it was this actor's first ever
audition for anything oh yeah oh well so
we had met him
i guess after season one or two and uh
well he's friends with our makeup artist
and he said that he had his first ever
audition for a movie television anything
and it was for our show
and um he went our casting director at
the time was a guy named john pepsidera
when we started the show and he goes to
john pepsidera's office
and he's as nervous as can be right he's
never auditioned for anything
and
he's got his head shots and he's he's he
knows his lines he's ready to go and
suddenly he has this like rumble on the
stomach of like you know and that like
tastes in your mouth and the sweat of
like tasting well i don't know just like
the dried taste in your mouth okay like
a dry mouth situation that you're the
watery the watery yeah you're bad that's
usually vomiting yeah that's bob that's
not where this is all right sorry well
this is coming out the other end so he
realizes he he's gonna have diarrhea
like he's like there's no way i'm not
having diarrhea and it's vomit of the
animals it's coming really bad
and yeah it's coming
yeah so he goes to the bathroom but just
before he gets to there uh someone some
actor actress goes in
and they lock the door and he's he's
waiting he's waiting and he can kind of
hear the person in there like rehearsing
their lines and they're taking forever
and he like taps on the door but they're
not coming out and then he's like i'm
not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it
so he goes in the alleyway behind the
casting office
and he's like a dumpster there and he
he doesn't quite make it he he has diary
in his pants he pulls his pants down
and he's like oh my god this is a mess
this
he's trying to salvage this situation he
has no toilet paper so he's wiping his
butt with his own head shots
and the sides and the side yeah pieces
of paper and photographs of himself he's
wiping his ass with pictures of himself
there's never been a greater metaphor
for hollywood yeah yeah
i mean
i mean
it's something out of like uh you know
like a ben stiller absolutely
straight out of a yeah and so
as the story goes he realizes
i'm done there's there's no i can't do
the audition i gotta go home
and he gets in his car and his pants are
so ruined and they're smelling the car
smell so bad that he like takes them off
and like i don't know if he throws them
out the window whatever but he's driving
home and no pants on and as he's driving
home with no pants on he gets rear-ended
oh my god
he gets rear-ended now the rest is kind
of hazing for me like i remember there's
like a homeless guy who looks in the
window and starts yelling like that
dude's got no pants on and anyway so we
heard the story and then i think we had
it he auditioned again he because we
didn't just like automatically give him
a part we had to make sure he could i
think yeah i know he auditioned for that
he he did but we we found out about it
after he had auditioned well that's
right so we probably would have just
given it to him anyway because of that
but then he read fortin was great and we
were like yes you hit you have earned
this role